si dice buongiorno buonasera
non lo so benvenuti perché vi voglio
tutti qui o no ho io vengo lì allora la
prima operazione che voglio fare è
un'operazione molto semplice
io prendo un occhiale questo occhiale me
l'ha regalato il mio padre nel 1970 e me
lo metto
oppure prendo questo chiave che di venti
giorni fa e me lo metto
ditemi voi con che cosa vi guardo con
questo occhiale o questo occhiale visto
che mi state dicendo che devo dire che
cosa capita nella comunicazione nel 2039
se mi mette il 38 io non so perché forse
perché rientrano che passava vicino a
casa mia il 38
allora molto difficile parlare di questo
tema ma non è che io vorrei soltanto se
possibile in pochi minuti darvi alcune
pennellate per far comprendere un po
meglio a noi stessi o apprendere come
siamo dentro in un mondo che
tendenzialmente ci dà le cose così come
sono e vorrebbe che noi lo consumassimo
così come sono e ci impedisce di vivere
i paradossi ci impedisce cioè di vivere
fuori dalle regole
tale per cui possiamo poi fertilizzare
le regole questo vale non soltanto per i
giovani vale anche per uno che se la
barba come me mi piacerebbe uscire dalle
figure di uno con la barba come se
appena prima potesse il primo elemento
che mi posso dare sostanzialmente è nel
2003 2038 non mi ricordo più vedi mi
serve una intelligenza artificiale nel
2039 avremo due eclissi ne avremo una
giugno ne avremo una dicembre fenomeno
rarissimo due crisi contemporaneamente
nello stesso anno prima di quindici anni
di quando nostradamus dice che ci sarà
una colossale situazione di guerra nel
mondo
tutto questo è probabile plausibile
improbabile come per devo comunicare in
un mondo di facebook che possa essere
credibile di che cosa posso fare o dire
delle cose tali per cui posso creare
delle condizioni di aspettativa più
bella rispetto a quella che vogliamo
vivere per esempio un primo assunto che
posso assumere che non è vero che tutto
comunicazione perché la comunicazione è
soltanto quella modalità che non è
un'azione che serve perché possano
avvenire le cose c'è la comunicazione è
il modo col quale l'informazione la
forma dell'energia prende forma io in
questo momento sto prendendo forma per
voi attraverso i vostri sensi miei sensi
io sto comunicando con voi ma io non sto
facendo niente se non fare così ma se
lei viene si alza e mi applaude cosa
dice levy che facesse ecco in questo
momento io vedo che lei sta facendo
un'azione manderò come mai lei sia
perché si è alzata mi faccia capire qual
è il motivo per cui l'ha fatto
e quante cose noi facciamo così per
esempio noi crediamo che l'uomo neander
di sneijder tar sia stato distrutto da
l'uomo sapiens giusto destituito da
fondamento
l'uomo di neanderthal stava morendo per
i cazzi suoi cioè non ce la faceva tutto
sommato nel gioco della specie non ce la
faceva era era era venuto fuori un po
non citadini non si sa da dove era
venuto fuori questo poiché noi chi non
lo sa bis ma lui non sapeva di essere
sapiens e incontra il neanderthal e noi
diciamo el'ha fatto fuori
l'ho ammazzato destituito da fondamento
lo ha coccolato
ha coccolato in modo tale che potesse
l'uomo sapersi imparare quelle cose che
il neanderthal sapeva per poter usare
meglio il rapporto con il fuoco che lui
aveva appena trovato ma non sapeva come
usarlo
allora che cosa vuol dire che le etnie
collaborano per il miglioramento non
combattono per il miglioramento
combattono per la supremazia
questo vorrebbe un dato importantissimo
importantissimo rispetto a quello che
noi abbiamo visto che questo mondo è un
mondo che ha una situazione climatica
negativa vero e se io mi domando la cina
in questa condizione climatica a che
punto è come unità personale di di
inquinamento a che punto primo secondo
posto settimo
come rispondete abbiamo lo stereotipo
che che è al primo posto
no è al penultimo penultimo e l'ultimo è
la india
l'america è la prima nell'unità
individuale rispetto all'energia che noi
trasformiamo in co2
l'opinione che noi abbiamo è
completamente sbagliata in questo
momento la cina sta ipotizzando sta
facendo 2.542 parchi industriali per
capire come abbassare il co2
quanti ne facciamo noi e allora io ho
tutti questi stereotipi tutto questo a
che fare con dei rapporti di
informazione di comunicazione che devo
cercare di comprendere come mai
vanno in una direzione abbiamo su quell
altra quindi semplifico la nostra vita
cosa sta avvenendo lo avete visto con il
professore che parlava dell'intelligenza
artificiale sta venendo la mutazione
veramente antropologica che è bellissimo
no ti sei messo un altro paio di
occhiali vuoi vedere le cose come il
futuro che vede le cose come il passato
qual è il rapporto tra in passato il
futuro beh facciamo fuori un altro
paradosso ipotizzate per un attimo che
io chiamo futuro tutto il passato che
c'è stato perché il passato che c'è
stato e stato in quel momento futuro
cioè io ho preso nel passato il treno
per venire qui c'è stata la frana è
quello era il mio futuro
giusto in quel momento che quel presente
io ho il futuro cioè di tutti i presenti
stanno condensando in quel nome futuro
tant'è vero che i latini e greci non
usavano il termine futuro al singolare
non l'avevano avevano i futuri avevano
le possibilità dei futuri allora che
cosa succede che se io devo abbattere in
chiave di comunicazione
l'idea di futuro devo fare in modo che
noi viviamo
quanti futuri ci sono in questa sala
mettete l'ipotesi che ciascuno di noi a
10 futuri possibili dopo aver incontrato
me che sono il presidente del futuro
quanti sono mettete che noi questo non
mezzo ha inviate a vedere se sto dicendo
delle cazzate verificando sullo
smartphone
nessuno l'ha fatto nessuno
giusto siete molto educati ma non siete
molto moderni non siete molto moderni
perché voi queste cose tu devi è venuto
ad applaudirlo e sono contento ha detto
prendi uno smartphone e vai a vedere chi
cazzo sto dicendo io perché è probabile
che vi sia inventato tutto visto che un
mondo di tecnica
a me è capitato con i ragazzi della mia
scuola un giorno gli stavo spiegando
come nello spazio takaya ci fosse una
sorta di ferro da stiro pam pam pam che
spacca il ghiaccio non lo taglia e
quattro di loro hanno aperto il loro
computer mentre io parlavo di un mio
benedetto mi sono sentito diminuito
nella mia autorità voi aprite il
computer mentre io parlo ma non che cosa
state facendo
cosa stai facendo perché se senso di
colpa ce l'hanno e c'erano il senso di
colpa
rimane senza di come che le mamme gli
hanno insegnato il senso di colpa
ma non lo sento note l'altro giorno gli
ho detto ma vuoi il preservativo lo
usate quando piove non ho mai detto che
cazzo di domanda è questa ha detto è
domandato se c'è da chivu o no il tuo
partner
no e allora stessa cosa e dirti ma
torniamo allo spazio anche per domani
poi vi lascio il ragazzo ma cosa stavano
facendo stavano verificandosi era vera
quello che stavo dicendo
in quel momento mi sono sentito tutta la
mia autorità che era diventata una
polpetta se fosse stato il papa che
sarebbe dimesso come la tring facevano
bene facevano bene
stavano imparando stavano apprendendo e
allora io che sono offerti non li ho
rimproverato perché avete tenuto la
vostra informazione per quattro non
l'avete data agli altri 20 perché quella
el intelligenza connettiva quella il
modo con il quale tutti noi creiamo
moltiplichiamo l'intelligenza e quindi
facciamo in modo che la comunicazione
cda l'energia per dare quelle
informazioni per fare quelle
informazioni per mettere in moto la
grammatica e la sintassi perché possa
avvenire ma abbiamo un problema grande
come una casa
noi possiamo in questo momento decidere
che nel 2039
abbiamo ceduto il passo agli algoritmi
che vuol dire che abbiamo tutto
matematici dato che vuol dire che nel
rapporto di algoritmo 0 1
io gioco tutta la mia partita legata ai
dati di informazione che possiedo e
siccome è un dato matematico numerico mi
trova di fronte a una situazione che una
situazione difficile da comprendere se
tutto diventa codificabile o meglio se
tutto diventa digitale dignità bile io
con un dito posso avere tutte le
connessioni del mondo tutte
tutte le informazioni le mille che dava
il professore più le 100 miliardi che ci
sono ma contemporaneamente ho perduto
il mio rapporto con la coscienza il mio
rapporto di questa parola nessuno la usa
nessuno tutti usano la parola mente
perché la mente si chiama mente perché
mente centro dc ragione no la
razionalità da il ragionamento la mente
dai il menti mento o no mente bene la
mia razionalità non mette la mia mente
mente il mio corpo mente la mia anima
mente ma la mia coscienza non mette ho
domandato al mio robot che una femmina è
il mio rovo e una femmina carina tutta
silhouette dico senti ma tu non hai
proprio coscienza e lei mi ha guardato
male ma ha detto di cosa stai parlando
io posso soltanto avere riflessione
posso solo riflettere
tu mi dai dei dati e io rifletto sui
lati moltiplico i dati
apprendo no imparo dai dati non apprendo
dai dati polemica con chi mi ha
proceduto ma non è importante
l'apprendimento è una cosa diversa
l'apprendimento a che fare con rapporto
che c'è tra l'informazione la
comunicazione se è tutta informazione io
solo entropia cioè non sono in grado di
comprendere la selezione
dell'informazione cosa che voi vivete
quando andate su uno smartphone
qualsiasi a vedere il numero di
informazioni che ci sono
e allora devo recuperare un aspetto
importante qual è l'aspetto della
produzione di senso la mia parte che
riguarda l'emotività la mia parte
emotiva non sta dentro un algoritmo
l'algoritmo è stato inventato dagli
arabi bravissimi da allora oltre che per
il petrolio hanno inventato lo zero
rispetto all'uno non conosceva noi non
conoscevamo 10 merlino spiega benissimo
lo zero ad artù e lancillotto lo zero
hanno invitato gli arabi
se lo metti primo se lo metti dopo
diventa una diminuzione o un
maggioritario giusto 01 cento
ma se tu guardi lo zero dice merlino e
tu pensi come è fatto e poi prendi le
tue braccia e fai lo zero e chiudi le
tue braccia ti trovi con niente niente
cioè lo zero è l'illusione che
l'illusione che noi viviamo che siccome
tutto è diventato matematico tutto è
algoritmico tutto e informativo tutto
questo servirà a costruire il senso per
noi no servirà a costruire il senso per
coloro che decidono che la parte emotiva
la possiamo mandare a casa 2039 dobbiamo
decidere la vogliamo ancora la domanda e
finisco la domanda è cosa sono disposto
a lasciare
e cosa sono disposto a tenere da quel
punto di vista posso poi trovare a
comunicare e lazio
[Applauso]